un momento histórico se trata de la
oficialización de la creación del centro
internacional para el enjuiciamiento de
crímenes de agresión contra Ucrania una
oficina internacional para investigar
los crímenes de Rusia respondiendo al
incesante reclamo de
propósito clave de tener el centro
internacional para el enjuiciamiento del
crimen de agresión es asegurar pruebas
cruciales comenzar a construir el caso
ya ahora no queremos esperar hasta el
final del conflicto
su objetivo es cerrar el vacío legal en
la Corte Penal Internacional dado que no
tiene potestad de enjuiciar la agresión
el principal crimen de guerra que
consiste en lanzar una guerra contra
otro país el organismo trabajará
conjuntamente con Fiscales de la Unión
Europea Estados Unidos y la cpi que
pueden procesar a los presuntos autores
de crímenes de guerra de lesa humanidad
y genocidio en Ucrania hace unos meses
la cpi emitió una orden de aprehensión
contra el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
Este es el marco dentro del cual
intercambiaremos información experiencia
pruebas de relación con el crimen de
agresión y diseñaremos e implementaremos
una estrategia común de investigación y
enjuiciamiento el trabajo del centro
contribuirá a la investigación y
enjuiciamiento eficientes e integrales
del crimen de agresión que es un pecado
original
en abril de 2022 empezó el reclamo del
gobierno de volodimir zelenski cuando
fueron descubiertos cientos de cadáveres
y fosas comunes tras las retiradas de
las tropas rusas de bucha